[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we we are
indeed very careful boys
i got a question for you guys here we go
oh okay so
here we go
everyone here is in a relationship
whether your boyfriend girlfriend
married or
an affair with a boyfriend boyfriend
over there or mother father
or
that's popular so um what would you do
if you were
not with the person you're with right
now you're [ __ ] all the fans
[Laughter]
every single every single [ __ ] one
there's a lot of hot fans oh dude we got
hot oh you're a fan cool let's [ __ ] dude
jk news
dude i be looking at other
people's fans and i'm like oh like who's
fans like who i'm not gonna say but a
lot of youtube a lot of youtubers
they're fans mr beast you're fans
some of those fans are like a traffic
accident waiting to happen but then at
our meet and greets though i'm like
we got the only fans i think he looks
like he's been wanting to talk this
whole time
whether you're single or or or you could
create your own hypothetical you could
be
in another relationship
with this hypothetical creature oh sex
with the fan the whole time mountain
dude so much sex man
mouth ass
vagina never took you for a [ __ ] anal
guy not but just to try i'm not do it i
just want to do it to a fan you're not a
you are not that kind of man
you're going to get so many dms slid in
don't play with fire my friend i don't
even know how to check my dms dude
you'll get it bro that's the real trick
yeah because i tag him on [ __ ] and then
he's like how do i reshare this stuff
and i'm like
you know how to do instagram as much as
i do we're good and we're social media
stars yeah okay what about you anthony
been dying to speak on something
anthony came up with this idea
off-camera i did and then he's like i
presented like eight topics and then
you're like oh they're all good and then
joe's like no let's talk about this i
can't [ __ ] wait to leave her
let's say
you weren't with
ninabeth pilipinos what have you never
met her
who would have never met her what would
you be doing right now do you guys think
you were okay so like first question do
you guys think your relationship types
meaning like
you know in general at this point in
life you think you'd be in a
relationship in a long-term relationship
do i still have this random kid running
around no
that came that came as a product
unexplained genetics
he said still like tycho's random now
he's a random kid i'm like my goodness
like jesus mom [ __ ]
saint mary yeah where i just had a kid
yeah i just [ __ ] exactly who's been
in the relationship longest maybe
how many years oh wait no bart wait what
up nick uh 12 years next 12 months
nick's vincent's heist since when 2008.
2010.
i feel like i've been in a relationship
for like so [ __ ] long because i
basically went out of one into another
so i've been like with like two chicks
you've been like
13 years old that's why i don't think
you are gonna crush fans at all thank
you you have never been single
since high school i know it was just a
defensive that's why he would crush
people because like the second the
second you've been in something for a
long time and you get out of it is the
second you go the opposite way for a
period of time i think what he'll do is
he'll find the first fan that he crushes
and falls in love with her and then
he'll stay with them nah dude my twitter
bio would be i anal fans
i think if
if i was single
with no random kid running around i
probably would try to crush puss because
i think my
my well my body count is only i think
like four or five oh jesus christ your
body oh i look like i'm a [ __ ]
casanova no because like so i had my i
lost my virginity when i was 15 right in
high school and then i had another chick
after that and then so three chicks you
got your virginity back maybe like three
chicks in high school or four chicks in
high school and then i was super
on track of just finding a relationship
so like you know when i was in college i
wasn't really i dated around but it was
so easy for me like i don't i'm not
feeling any there was [ __ ] being thrown
at him and he went you don't have
straight a's
you ain't no [ __ ] lie bro yeah cause
i went from one site like another and
then uh me and geo got together in 2008
and then so it's just been
like a loop you'd be like people like
hey girl let's go to the beach [ __ ] all
this school work [ __ ] and he's at the
beach and he's all like hey joe you know
i got so turned off because she actually
played into my trick and went to the
beach with me yeah she got distracted
and he's like that means she's not an
ace that turned you off you played so
many money i was weird man was maybe
i don't know yeah but we would we would
have study groups or whatever and check
i'll be with the chick and then i'm like
hey you wanna go to the beach yeah sure
she's wearing like this hot bikini and
[ __ ] i'm like don't try to [ __ ] trick
me you're not a good student
and then uh i wouldn't end up not
talking to them anymore this girl's like
you wanna come to the pool party he goes
sure and he goes to the pool party and
then he was like where is the party it's
just us too well might as well get in
the jacuzzi
and then they just get in there together
you talk about school how old are you
wow i don't know 23 24 25. i didn't
realize that's when you were ucla though
right yeah i didn't know i was like you
were like i'm like where's all your
friends at you said there's a pool party
and then she was like oh they all
couldn't make it she's lying to you bro
and i'm like that's that's a red flag no
no no that's the red guys your friends
are very flaky
you are the average of the people you
hang out with
and then barco's homemade goes so you
think she likes me i actually don't like
people who suck at planning events
either so now because i'm what 30 all of
your friends 38 this year and i only
have
like four or five then if you never met
geo you might have been
continuously trying to crush or try to
get married no i mean like like you had
that
yeah yeah it's like actually found
yourself a little bit sooner and maybe
start to crush a little bit because then
you have like eight years of blue balls
or something yeah cause when you look
back on all the times that you were a
[ __ ] idiot and the chicks were trying
to [ __ ] you it's actually pretty wild
how stupid guys are yeah cause like damn
that chick was totally trying to [ __ ] me
i was like how did i not know that same
chick i remember she brought my sweater
right
i'm like
this one in the moment you're just so
[ __ ] dumb i remember she bought my
sweater she was like sweatshirt we go on
the balcony and she's like you know
what's weird i remember like all the
black guys at my school would give me
attention because i was like one of the
white chicks with the big booty i'm like
oh i can't believe they would look at
your butt like that i'm like it's just
me and her in the room it's so [ __ ] up
you generally felt like though uh but
you do have the sweater that you
borrowed right
can i have my sweater back i'm like i'm
just so [ __ ] dumb that i just yes
i've got my sweater back all right cool
see you tomorrow
and that's the classic move right ladies
love it
and i'll probably go home [ __ ] horny
and i'm like i guess i gotta jack off
because no one wants to [ __ ] me
but that explains you in a nutshell like
spurned by another white woman
damn these white girls play harder get
don't they they don't they'll never like
an asian guy like me
you know hollywood need to put more
asians on the map dude
come on come on come on
for the sake of this hypothetical
um don't try to butter it up dude just
say it
this i i wouldn't have ever said this
when i was younger
but uh for the sake of the social
understanding and the experience of it
uh this sounds so weird to try and say
but i feel like i would
try
and test online dating
just because i feel like that's such a
unique human experience that was so not
not apparent for us
not tender oh cause you're not part of
the tinder generation yeah we never did
it i never did it yeah we all skipped
out we were my space generation though
that's
elite online dating and there was
definitely a moment where it's kind of
like man that's just so weird like the
e-harmonies the tinder the coffee right
yeah and then now it's like straight up
like years later obviously the world has
gone so digital and social and we all
know probably now people who are happily
married you know what i mean and when
you think about it too it's like oh my
god you guys met on online video that's
so weird but it's like over here it's
like where'd you guys meet the [ __ ]
club like it's not exactly like romantic
either you know so i feel like for the
social understanding and like
there must be something really cool
about like kind of you know just kind of
not beating around the bush and just
being like you want something i want
something let's see if it [ __ ] works
out if not i can swipe move to the next
one and kind of go through that quick
and also
straight up on the whole crush push [ __ ]
there's so many yeah there's so many
people that like use those platforms and
meet people and the long-term
relationship doesn't work but the
short-term fun exists yeah you know what
i'm saying you're a dirty dog anthony
would be a tender swindler bro that's
who he would turn out
don't be
don't be blowing that [ __ ] up
dude anthony's going on a fan
fuck-a-thon bro
hundred percent
oh this guy's ceo of his own company
oh the noodles were his
i eat those
two instagrams he's in charge of
i get those at texas costco and hawaii
7-eleven
kinderbang noodles is just getting a
bunch of dms
today's video is brought to you by
upstar if you got multiple credit card
balances and you're getting by just by
paying the minimums and barely making a
debt in your credit card debt it can be
pretty dang discouraging upstart can
help you pay off your existing debt
quickly so you can finally feel like
you're getting ahead whether you're
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or finding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment find you a
smarter rate for your loan with a
five-minute rate check you could see
your rate up front from loans of 1 000
to up to fifty thousand dollars and
receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today by going to
upstart.com
off the record that's upstart.com
off the record don't forget to use the
url so they know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined by your
credit income and certain other
information provided on your loan
application go to upstart.com
off the record i think i think i would
be in a relationship
at my age right now
you are in a relationship yeah yeah but
i i think uh if maybe another one or
whatever but i think i'd be in a steady
relationship
yeah that's it that's all you got well
because i i got to do the crush push
stuff
and i [ __ ] i [ __ ] so many fans oh
yeah
i know you're wrecking those fans dude
you're getting a real hard time it was
so good but why would you why would you
be why would you not continue to the
fuck-a-thon why would you because
they're breaking his back my balls hurt
no i think there's a there's a
there's a point where
there's a point where you want more
like there's a point where you want a
companion than a hookup or like you want
more out of the relationship he brought
out this prompt so he could [ __ ] look
like the hero
he does but is there
is there a moment like honestly like
actually when you're with a when you're
with somebody and you're having that
existential moment like maybe you're
biting down on the sheet and you're like
yeah
god damn it man he's like i don't know
like is there more one tear comes out of
his eye as he's biting the sheets
when i'm when i'm hugging the pillow in
my doggy style position yeah and and i'm
getting my ass licked and i shiver and
bite the pillow
oh [ __ ] do i go
shimmer don't shiver
and you go
maybe someone else could lick it better
than this yeah
the curiosity got it
is there more out of life you know or
someone that could love you harder you
know what you mean do you think your dad
watches these videos
yeah
he's a huge fan yeah and he goes man if
you i never beat your ass if you got
your ass licked like that
if i knew you're such a sexual maverick
so by the way i don't remember beating
your ass i think regardless if i'm in a
relationship or not i always want to
crush push
yeah i think that's just a in inherent
guy [ __ ]
it's just
hard not to desire it right for the sake
of the camera i don't cosign to that but
then when you like shut up
that's why there's even two fingers
there's one in the ass exactly
you could have made a one little
circular motion or you could have hit
all five but you're like nah dude i
think what prevents normal human beings
from doing it
is the guilt of hurting the person you
like or love yeah yeah but it doesn't
still prevent you from wanting to bone
the [ __ ] out of a lot of uh
perspectives do you think the husband
ever goes to his wife he's like hey look
i didn't [ __ ] her
i fisted her
and she's like oh okay that's it i was
like oh that's less intimate
does that ever happen before i just
worried about this
no i've never participated in fisting i
don't think i would i would uh enjoy
your party
i've never had a i've never had a uh
interest in physically you'll see why
that would be enjoyable for the woman
i think my my fist is too small actually
i have small hands i never had a desire
to fist a woman
but i did watch a porno where
a girl [ __ ] the bed post and it was
the size of a fist oh wow and she was
riding a bed like the the corner like a
victorian bed yeah it was like one of
those
solid or more modern that's going to do
it
like a pride and prejudice
it was one of the ones that had the
[ __ ] mosquito net excuse me beauty
dude like [ __ ] huge dude with the
swirls and [ __ ]
hand crafted
beauty and the beast left one of one an
anne of green gables bedbugs
basically and she rode that [ __ ] and i
was like god not anne of avonlea where
they lost the budget yeah not that one
that's where they lost the budget but it
blows my mind cause i'm like what man
watches this and goes ooh time to jack
off yeah who's that for not me and how
did you stumble upon it and watching it
hey don't judge me okay i randomized you
you said what man watch this you're the
one watching it you're the one that
likes ben post [ __ ] well you put
portal on shuffle you could do that it's
on autoplay what is it oh
what is that
i never thought of that dude do you have
a porn playlist yeah i do i have
favorites but then
don't you just go on the front page and
go like hmm what am i feeling window
shopping or don't you go on like the
what's hot like today's hottest trends
you know like daily special yeah the
daily special and then you see it kind
of like oh what's this there's a maid
and then you click and then you're like
skipping through
you know and then you're like hey i've
never seen this before and she starts
writing a bed post
that's what happens a lot when i watch
stuff like
it happens a lot trust me i'm not i'm
not talking i'm not clicking the title
joe's like okay for example i picked a
video this chick's on an island i'm like
there's surely not going to be a bed
post
sure enough
out of [ __ ] nowhere
she sits on the bed
and she starts riding no bed frame no
bed for miles no bed frame just a bad
frame post there's a best boat you
explain that to me actually
yeah
yeah
all right i remember i saw a threesome
right
a threesome go down with a chicken and a
couple of bed poses
what about you guys what about you guys
over there what do you think you would
be if you guys weren't in a relationship
right now i beat another relationship
because i'm a [ __ ]
there we go
there we go 100
i'm a [ __ ]
yeah cause like sometimes this question
is very weird like for me friends why is
it weird well like just for you though
yeah well because you've been with one
person since high school but i've also
yeah
high school was what's up would you
still be in high school
[Laughter]
think no i don't think i'd be crushing
puss bro like i don't think i'm the guy
bro i i don't think so no no no [ __ ] no
no you never thought like you've never
been that guy huh i i did it okay so
nick's not that horny well
you're not horny let me touch you you'd
be touching my dick
so like don't be afraid to be honest but
at the same time be afraid here no i'm
being a hundred percent because i have
to deserve when i i remember uh ethylene
would go again after you there was a
girl that i told the story about how
like she kind of like dumped me or
whatever yeah and then after i started
like i stopped talking to her and i kind
of really didn't like her at all because
and i started being mean to her and then
she started really liking me
and then she was like you should come
over blah blah and i went over to her
house and then like
i guess i think she wanted to have sex
with me
and like we started making out and then
i just was like
this don't feel right and i left why
because i just it didn't feel like your
dick didn't get hard yeah bro i felt
like i felt bad i felt like get hard
really
nah what what do you think was bad about
it well because i i knew that i didn't
really like her because it was your best
friend's girlfriend at a time no
no
but like it was one of those things
where i just couldn't like
i felt dirty
afterwards
guilt will [ __ ] with you it's because it
was just physical and nothing like yeah
like i just couldn't i was like what's
the point i don't even like this chick
like just have to like [ __ ] through that
though you're [ __ ] yeah but i also at
the time i was also a virgin too i was
also a virgin so i also was kind of like
i don't know
and i just was like i don't know bro
this is the same like it just didn't
feel right so then i just left and i
just never talked to her because you
want your first time to be magical yeah
i guess yeah no for sure but but at the
same time especially at the age but also
too it's like i've been with my girl for
so long
even in my formative years you know like
where i don't even know like my life
might be completely different i don't
think i maybe would have even started
fighting at that still be a white belt
huh yeah i don't even know like i don't
even know how different my life was so
she played such a giant role in who you
are and what you've become today yeah we
grew up to like we grew together as
adults wow like in like you know i
remember life before nicki really not
really
we're not supposed to bring the real
people back into this prompt guys
no but but in general like i'd be
helicoptering fans you forced him to get
like such a weird answer that we all get
real
everybody's such a [ __ ] hero no no
but in general though like in all
reality yeah i probably would be in a
relationship but like is that a fun
answer yeah no dude what if you guys
asked me and i just went i'd be in a
relationship and they just continued
i said the same thing and it was pretty
fun i think why is it important than
what it actually is yeah no but i think
i think i am a relationship kind of guy
you know when you said you were going to
helicopter fans were you the propeller
so yeah so where's the pilot when you
hit
when you helicopter somebody
you mouth a chick like this right oh
she's on top she's on top okay
um
but then it's time to say but it's time
to take off
it's time to take off you tell her that
too yeah yeah
through the through the headset though
so r kelly's ignition remix you say work
here for takeoff and then you just start
[ __ ] rotating around your dick i
thought you were the propeller
so i thought you're getting on top and
speaking like a [ __ ] no but
that's too much work for me we
established earlier though i have to go
like this when i have sex that's true oh
okay he's a real man thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you